les étudiants du québec paie de plus en
plus pour aller à l'université
en 20 ans selon mes calculs les frais
afférents t'exploser 278% et alors que
la facture étudiante à augmenter l'accès
à des professeurs lui a diminué en 97 il
y avait en moyenne un professeur pour 20
étudiants dans les universités
au fil des ans ce ratio a grimpé jusqu'à
atteindre 25 étudiants par professeur en
2015 alors que les étudiants ont eu de
moins en moins accès des professeurs
leur facture elle n'a cessé d'augmenter
en 1997 un étudiant résidant au québec
et à temps plein paient en moyenne 2008
140 $ par année une fois l'inflation
prise en compte en 2016 c'était 3699
dollar
pour bien comprendre comment cette
hausse est produite
il faut décomposer la facture étudiante
en deux éléments les droits de scolarité
et les frais afférents
les droits de scolarité sont fixés par
le gouvernement du québec
l'état les avait gelé pendant des années
avant de les faire augmenter rapidement
vous vous rappelez sans doute du
printemps érable en 2012 mais quand on
prend en compte l'inflation ces droits
de scolarité n'ont pas vraiment bougé en
1997 tout comme en 2016
il était d'environ 2300 $ pour un
étudiant à temps plein donc ce ne sont
pas les droits de scolarité qui font en
sorte que les étudiants paient plus
aujourd'hui qu'il y a vingt ans ce sont
les frais afférents
ces frais sont à la discrétion des
universités en 1997 un étudiant paient
en moyenne 499 $ en frais afférents
vingt ans plus tard 7388 dollars une
hausse de 178 pour ça
quand on les analyse en détail on se
rend compte que les universités facture
toutes sortes de frais supplémentaires
aux étudiants
cependant il ne faut pas oublier deux
choses la facture étudiante du québec
est l'une des plus basses en amérique du
nord
quand on se compare aux autres provinces
canadiennes et aux états américains on
se console et l'aide financière aux
études a augmenté aussi en 20 ans il
n'en reste pas moins que le système
universitaire est sous pression
il n'y a jamais eu autant de québécois
qui fréquentent l'université
qu'aujourd'hui et ça amène son lot de
défis pour lire le reportage complet
avec ma méthodologie 7 ici
[Musique]